by now you've probably seen the music  video that's spreading hope throughout  the internet it's called the American  prayer song so many celebrities  participated this is the sky their  famous beautiful talented but they're  also foreigners not much of an American  prayer is it the songs co-writer he goes  by a one-word name foreigner this reggae  star writes anti-gay songs miss my  buy-in about the boy but what's worse is  you guessed it he's a foreigner why get  Joss Stone when there's a homegrown girl  who could use a gig who needs this  foreigner when you've got the All  American cop Danny Glover stop  outsourcing roles and pro-obama videos  to foreigners this is my American prayer  this is my hate for my cabbage creative  artists for Barack and American jobs